this is one of nature's most mesmerizing
Nana's the humpback whale the name
humpback comes from the signature motion
makes as its back clears the water
before a dive
adult humpbacks average between 35 to 50
feet in length and weigh about a ton per
foot they can live up to 60 years and
remain underwater on a single breath for
up to 30 minutes
an average humpback whale will eat some
2,000 pounds of alaska's plentiful
plankton krill and small schooling fish
each day during feeding season and each
year North Pacific humpback whales like
these make a three thousand mile trek
leaving the frigid waters of their
Alaskan feeding grounds for the warm
waters of
Hawaii I mean come on wouldn't you
they come here to mate and give birth
living on all that food they ate all
summer in Alaska here's a cow and her
calf breaching or leaping out of the
water whether it's for courtship play or
some other reason scientists aren't
exactly sure why humpbacks breach here's
a nearby male slapping is 14 foot long
pectoral fin on the water this is called
Peck slapping which may be for
communication
[Music]
humpbacks also display other fascinating
behaviors like this tail slap otherwise
known as the lob tailing the sled may
serve as a warning and can be heard
underwater for hundreds of feet and the
most fascinating of all the singing only
the male's sing these complex eerie
exquisite songs and only in Hawaii each
male starts by singing its own song but
by the end of the season they're all
singing the same tune come back whales
are an endangered species
researchers believe they're about ten to
twelve thousand humpbacks left in the
ocean places like the Hawaiian Islands
humpback whale National Marine Sanctuary
have been designated to make sure they
survive
[Music]